with vast expanses of wind lashed and
sparsely populated highlands it's no
surprise Scotland has flown the flag for
wind power in the UK in fact renewable
energy supplies almost half Scotland's
electricity and the country's government
wants that to reach 100 percent by 2020
here on the Orkney Islands north of the
mainland that's already the case in fact
these islands produce more than they can
use but there's much more than just wind
power here so this is the place in 2004
when wave energy first supplied energy
into the National Grid is the first time
that been done anywhere in the world
this is like alchemy returning seawater
into electricity you know this is not
easy this site is part of eMac the
European marine energy center the
company was set up over 10 years ago to
develop the marine devices of the future
and there's good reason to invest some
in the green industry think a fifth of
the UK's energy can come from the sea at
this site seven developers are working
on machines that harness the power of
the waves the device is very Sun Bob on
the surface others rock back and forth
on the seabed on another part of the
island conditions are better suited for
tidal devices these make use of the sea
currents most devices in development are
large turbines fixed to the seabed while
these have advantages they can be costly
to repair this device by Scott
renewables is a floating turbine it
harnesses tidal currents near the
surface as well as being relatively
cheap to construct the design offers
other advantages these small repairs we
can do at sea obviously because it's
floating the vast majority of the
electrical components are situated in
the hull and they can be accessed via
hatch at sea this prototype is being
replaced by a commercial device that
will generate eight times as much output
making it the most powerful marine
turbine device in the world whether an
independent scotland makes the most of
disputed North Sea oil the levels of
innovation in alternative energy a
second to none according to researchers
Bloomberg New Energy Finance indepen
threatens to discourage green investment
so the question might not be whether or
not these devices will be powering the
world's homes in years to come but
whether or not they'll still be in
Scotland Ron Gibson Bloomberg